are you looking to gain more respect
from those around you do you want to
learn how to Captivate people's
attention and be a true leader if so
then you won't want to miss this
inspiring video how to make people
respect you immediately in this video
you'll discover 9 powerful strategies
that you can use to gain immediate
respect from those around you from
learning how to listen well to speaking
last like Nelson Mandela to being able
to laugh at yourself like Will Smith
this video offers practical and
actionable advice that you can start
implementing today imagine the feeling
of command in a room where everyone is
hanging on your every word and
respecting your opinion this video will
teach you how to become that kind of
leader one that people naturally
gravitate towards and look up to so what
are you waiting for join the millions of
viewers who've already checked out this
Channel and start learning how to make
people respect you immediately your
journey towards becoming a respected and
admired leader Starts Here enjoy
way number one is be the last to speak
with Simon signic Nelson Mandela is a
particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
Nelson Mandela across the world is
he was actually the son of a tribal
Chief and he was asked one day how did
you learn to be a great leader and he
responded that he would go with his
father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things one they would
always sit in a circle and two his
father was always the last to speak you
will be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed and two you
get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes if you disagree
with somebody don't not know simply sit
there take it all in and the only thing
you're allowed to do is ask questions so
that you can understand what they mean
and why they have the opinion that they
have and at the end you will get your
turn it sounds easy it's not practice
being the last to speak that's what
Nelson Mandela did way number two is be
able to laugh at yourself with Will
Smith I gotten probably two weeks into
my preparation for the film and my
father was diagnosed with cancer so we
just started talking about love time and
death and we we it was some of the most
open and Powerful conversations that we
you know we we ever had and um they gave
him six weeks and uh he actually he
lived for four months so about three
months into the six weeks you know I go
to see him one day and he said man this
is embarrassing
and I said what daddy said man you tell
everybody you won't be dead in six weeks
three months later you still hanging
around
laughing is the Elixir you know and that
was another thing that my father taught
me he was he was joking all the way up
to the end like laughing you have to be
able to laugh at everything and for me
the beautiful part is uh that that's my
natural
um uh color on the Spectrum I naturally
go-to comedy you know and when when when
I'm looking at something I'm always
trying to find why that's funny and you
know it's been really really helpful in
in this experience and and you know even
just uh this point in my life keep
remember to laugh remember to laugh and
and spend time with people that make you
laugh like that is hugely important way
number three is let your actions speak
louder than your words with Eric Thomas
I need you to transition from the eye
today
whoa that's right I said it transitioned
from the eye and what's an eye the eye
is an idea that's all it is it's an idea
so I want us to do more a than I that's
right I want us to live in the A and not
the I what do I mean by that some people
man they got an idea and all you do is
talk talk every time you get an idea you
pick up the phone you call your homegirl
you three-way you get on conference call
and you getting excited about your idea
all right you telling your mom about it
your daddy about it and you there's more
life in you when you talk about the idea
than you put any action in it are you
hearing me so do me a huge favor write
the idea down and then shut up you heard
what I said write the idea down and shut
up you ain't got to share your idea with
50 people write the idea down and boom
get your stepping baby get to the action
because listen to me very closely your
success is not determined on just what
you say now I'm not just I'm not
disagreeing with the you got to speak
stuff into existence I'm not disagreeing
with that but I'm telling you you can't
talk about it all the time you got to be
about it so I want some action so that
what does that mean that means when you
wake up in the morning there's 24 hours
in a day after you finish sleeping right
and I don't know how much sleep you need
right that's just big debate ET how much
sleep do I need I don't have a slice
idea I know how much I need you might
need five you might need six you might
need seven you might need eight I don't
know that's your business but listen to
what I'm telling you after you have
finished sleeping after you finish
eating and if you just that immature and
you need to get your play on every day
you need to play video games I don't
know you need to play cards I don't know
what you need to do whatever you need to
do after you finish exercising I'm
telling you to spend the rest of that
time in action and you're gonna separate
yourself from everybody why because most
people all they doing is talk talk talk
talk that's all they doing is talk talk
talk talk and they getting pumped up and
they're getting excited from talking so
I'm saying get out of neutral and get it
in the drive the majority of your day so
on Monday I want you to have 10 write
down the things to do list and I want
you to say at the end of the day if I
wrote down 20 things what did I get done
and I'm trying to tell you at the end of
Monday at the end of Tuesday after
Wednesday at the end of Thursday at the
end you get what I'm saying this ain't
rocket science at the end of your week
if you were supposed to get 60 things
done and you got 40 things done you're
going to be average at the end of the
week if you're supposed to get 60 things
up and you got 50 done you're gonna be
pretty good but at the end of the week
if you got 58 59 60 things done out of
60. let me tell you something you're
going to separate yourself from
everybody else are you hearing what I'm
saying all right all right all right all
I'm trying to tell you is this don't let
your words guide you let your actions
guide you are you hearing me don't let
guide you and if you spend the majority
of your day writing stuff down and then
fulfilling it you're going to be tight
work so stop listen to me stop getting
all pumped up about an idea everybody
has one everybody got a dream everybody
got to go stop dreaming about it stop
talking about it and get up and do
something about it that a baby that
action that action that grinding that
waking up and grinding way number four
is say what you mean with vinod cosla we
put this sort of slogan I prefer brutal
honesty to hypocritical politeness
on our website because it's a real
disservice to people
you don't have to be offensive to be
honest
um when I don't like somebody I can't
get offensive to but generally you can
be constructive and very honest and I
prefer that brutal honesty because it
serves a purpose the receiver can do
something about it if it's a
constructive criticism
if you get hypocritical politeness you
might lose
a lot so again it's about having enough
confidence to say the other person will
eventually appreciate it and that's
local good slogan came after I was
working on a company with another major
Venture firm and I didn't believe their
plan would work
they had 45 50 million dollars in the
bank account so everybody was
comfortable too comfortable in my view I
talked to the founders why it wouldn't
work
what my concerns were the other VCS
agreed with me in the board meeting said
all these polite things
you know so 40 Engineers wasted three or
four years of their life
because nobody was willing to tell them
the honest truth about what they really
thought
I and I swore I would never let anybody
waste their life at least give them the
best advice I had to give
and tell them I may be wrong but I'm not
gonna say something I don't believe in I
just won't
ah in
and that's extremely valuable to the
other thing but to be honest look there
are situations you can it offends people
and I offend people often
but it helps them if they really
introspective that's founder by the way
in that company called me four years
later
after after this company this company
got sold for three million dollars for
three and a half four years later
um sad story and he called me a year
after that said I only want to work with
you on my next venture uh because I wish
somebody had told me also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there way number five is see the good
and everything and everyone with Kevin
Hart life is too short and I feel like
everyone needs to live love and laugh
and understand like you know you're
constantly evolving things are
constantly changing things are
constantly putting new putting people in
position can get better and do better
we're doing a lot better A lot better
you're going to have bumps in a rope
you're going to have things that happen
that make you have a hiccup and and
question are we doing better but that's
life that's the course of life but you
know I I'm I'm a I'm a positive person
I'm a realistic and positive person so I
see where we are I'm happy where we are
and I know we can be five or ten years
from now it can continue to get better
and grow way number six is give credit
when it's due with LeBron James honestly
uh you guys seeing me sitting uh sitting
in this chair and kept looking over at
them it's because I'd rather be sitting
over there with them
I know this is an individual award but I
would much rather be sitting over there
in shorts in a t-shirt wondering what
the hell they joking about
because I want to be a part of that joke
and I hate being out of all the jokes I
want to know what was happening okay
guys I would much rather be with my guys
over there because that's what it's all
about
yeah much rather be with those guys
without those guys
this trophy is not possible
the Larry O'Brien Trophy last year is
not possible
nothing that I receive individually is
impossible without those 14 guys because
of what they sacrifice each and every
day you know the sweat and the blood and
the time and everything
um
I always know that what team success
becomes
individual prizes individual accolades
but
this really doesn't mean much to me I'm
humbled and I'm happy about it
but I wish it was 15 of these up here
because I'm with a great group of guys
that allow me to be the MVP
each and every night way number seven is
give respect to other people respect
others okay the Golden Rule you've heard
it for years you've heard it since
you've been little everybody's like oh
treat others the way that you want to be
treated it sounds simple right but
gentlemen I'm here to tell you respect
is a two-way street if you don't show
others respect and consideration for
their views or feelings don't expect
them to respect you or yours the deal is
we don't have to agree with people we
don't have to see things eye to eye or
on the same level but the fact is you
need to respect where they're coming
from and try to understand you may not
okay you may come to the conclusion that
they're bad crazy but at the end of the
day you listened and you tried to
understand and guess what they're gonna
respect you for respecting them another
aspect of respecting others is don't bad
mouth people don't talk behind
somebody's back if you've got a problem
if you've got an issue if you've got
something you need to say to somebody
say it you can do it in a respectful
manner that enables communication as
opposed to backstabbing gossip way
number eight is always strive to do
better with Terry Crews how many times
have you ever heard the phrase you are
perfect just as you are have you heard
that a lot man you know what you are
perfect just as you are you are so
perfect just as you are well you know
what you are not
you are not perfect just as you are you
are perfect
but you're not complete this is the
thing and this is what I mean by that
and a lot of people are going to go oh
what do you mean what are you trying to
say I gotta change I gotta change
somebody else yes yes you need to change
everybody everybody out there needs to
change we are designed for change
nothing in this world stays the same you
are either getting better or you are
getting worse and let me describe
something to you when I say you are
perfect but you are not complete
let's say this building I'm in if I
looked at the blueprints for this
building it
the blueprints for this building before
it was built were perfect
everything was in its Place everything
was great but could I walk in it
could I do anything did I have a
building no why it wasn't complete when
they framed up this building and put
wood and metal and all this stuff but
they didn't do the floor it didn't do
the electrical was it perfect yes it was
perfect but it wasn't complete you I
like this building you are perfect in
every way but you're just not done
you're not done and you know what
anybody's trying to tell you don't try
to change me you know now no one should
try to change you but you have to change
yourself
you are you owe it to everyone to change
yourself into a better person into a
better human being that's what you have
to do you are perfect but you're just
not complete so when you look at
yourself look at yourself at that
building and it's framed up and
everything is in its right place but
you're just not done I want to tell you
that so anybody who's trying to tell you
that I'm perfect just the way I am is
not trying to change and guess what
you're not and it's not working you're a
half done building who wants to live in
a building with no roof nobody and I'm
just trying to break it down to you that
you hear these catchphrases you hear
this stuff all the time but everybody
just takes it and says oh yeah I'm
perfect just the way I am and you don't
change and your life doesn't change and
nothing is better for you and you wonder
what's happening and everything is
crumbling around you hey I'm guilty
Terry Crews is guilty then I realize
wait a minute wait a minute I'm not
perfect just the way I am I have to be
perfected I am perfect but I am not
complete and way number nine is help
others when they need it and ask for
help when you need it I'm an ordinary
man with an extraordinary job right not
the other way around so it's all gravy
for me you know when I was younger
I used to coach a lot and nothing made
is you coach kids sports nothing made me
happier than seeing other people do well
well that's sort of my nature and that
and directing was the perfect job for
that because I love seeing others do
well I mean I'm I'm okay I did pretty
good I'm good I've done all right but to
see others do
what you know they're what they're
capable of
gives me great joy today I want to talk
about purpose
but I'm not here to give you the
standard commencement about finding your
purpose or millennials
we try to do that instinctively
instead I'm here to tell you that
finding your purpose isn't enough
the challenge for our generation is to
create a world where everyone has a
sense of purpose
one of my favorite stories
is when JFK went to go visit the NASA
Space Center and he saw a janitor
holding a broom and he asked him what he
was doing and the janitor replied Mr
President I'm helping put a man on the
moon
purpose is that feeling that you are a
part of something bigger than yourself
that you are needed and that you have
something better ahead to work for
purpose is what creates true happiness I
remember that night I launched Facebook
from
that little dorm in Kirkland house
I went to Nokes with my friend KX
and I remember telling him clearly that
I was excited to help connect the
Harvard Community but one day someone
would connect the whole world
the thing is it never even occurred to
me that that someone might be us we were
just college kids we didn't know
anything about that
there were all these great big
technology companies with all these
resources and I just assumed one of them
would do it
but this idea was so clear to us that
all people want to connect
so we just kept working on it day after
day after day
and I know that a lot of you are going
to have your own stories just like this
a change in the world that seems so
clear that you are sure someone else is
going to do it
but they're not you will
but it's not enough to have that purpose
yourself
you also have to create a sense of
purpose for others now maybe you're
asking yourself
can I really do this
well remember when I told you about that
class I taught at the Boys and Girls
Club
one day after class I was talking to my
students about
going to college and one of my top
students raised his hand and said that
he wasn't sure he could go to college
because he's undocumented
he wasn't sure if they'd take him
last year I took him out to breakfast
for his birthday
and I wanted to get him a gift so I
asked him what he wanted and
he just started talking about struggles
that he saw other students in his class
facing and
finally said you know I'd really just
like a book on social justice
I was blown away
here is a young guy who has every reason
to be cynical
he wasn't sure if the country he calls
home
the only one he's known
was going to deny him his dream of going
to college
but he wasn't feeling sorry for himself
he wasn't even thinking of himself
he has a greater sense of purpose and
he's going to bring people along with
him
it says something about our situation
today that I can't even say his name
because I don't want to put him at risk
but if a high school senior
who doesn't know what the future holds
for him
can do his part to move the world
forward then we owe it to the world to
do our part too what I learned is that I
don't have to know all the answers and
if I don't I don't have to pretend that
I do the opportunity to ask others for
help and admit when we don't know things
and even admit when we make mistakes
means that people will rush to our Aid
and will be there to help us if we claim
we know the answer is if we hide the
mistakes we make then people will think
things are fine and so they'll leave us
alone
and it's not that people don't want to
help us it's that they it's that they
don't know when they can because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Nelson Mandela
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there we put our foot
down and insisted in being respected
even though we're prisoners she said who
are you to ask for my name what's your
name you have a limited time to stay